this morning the Supreme Court clarified
a point of law but the very point of
democracy in this Union is now at stake
and democracy will not be denied because
whether Westminster likes it or not last
year the people of Scotland voted for a
Scottish Parliament with a majority in
the mandate to deliver an independence
the Prime Minister has every right to
oppose Independence he has no right to
deny democracy to the people of Scotland
if the Prime Minister keeps blocking
that referendum will they at least be
honest and confirmed that the very idea
that the United Kingdoms is a voluntary
Union of Nations is now dead and buried
well Mr Speaker let me start by saying
we respect the clear and definitive
ruling of the on the Supreme Court
and what I would say to The Honorable
gentleman that first thing I am looking
forward to also seeing the moderator of
Scotland tomorrow and I think that the
people of Scotland want us to be working
on fixing the major challenges that we
collectively face whether that's the
economy supporting the NHS or indeed
supporting Ukraine now is the time for
politicians to work together and that's
what this government will do in
Blackfoot
Mr Speaker it is right that we respect
the decision of the Court
[Applause]
now democracy and the very same breath
if democracy is to matter if elections
matter then mandates matter since 2014
the Scottish national party has won
eight elections in a row last year we
won a landslide the Scottish Parliament
now has the biggest majority for an
independence referendum in the history
of devolution the Prime Minister doesn't
even have a personal mandate to sit in
10 Downing Street what right does a man
with no mandate have to deny Scottish
democracy
but Mr Speaker when when it comes to
Scottish democracy I'm pleased that this
the Scottish government has one of the
most powerful devolved assemblies
anywhere in the world
and I'm pleased and I was pleased very
shortly after becoming prime minister to
be the first Prime Minister in over a
decade to attend the council to sit down
with the first minister to explore ways
in which we can work together with the
Scottish government to deliver for the
people of Scotland whether that's
delivering our growth deals delivering
freeports or ensuring that the 1.5
billion pounds of extra Barnet money can
go towards supporting Public Services
that's what we're committed to doing in
Scotland